Jadi apa itu Qiskit?
Qiskit adalah software development kit open source
untuk bekerja dengan komputer kuantum
di level circuit,
algoritma, dan modul aplikasi. SDK ini
memungkinkan siapa saja untuk memprogram komputer kuantum sungguhan dari
laptop mereka. Hanya dengan dua baris kode, kamu bisa mengakses
beberapa sistem kuantum, mulai dari superkonduktor
hingga trapped-ion qubit. Mau mensimulasikan perilaku komputer kuantum?
Tinggal ubah satu baris kode saja,
dan simulasikan quantum circuit kamu di simulator
berperforma tinggi kami. Qiskit adalah alat yang dipakai oleh puluhan
ribu orang di seluruh dunia yang berusaha
membangun masa depan. Apakah kamu peneliti, developer,
atau baru mau mulai belajar,
Qiskit punya banyak
fitur yang tersedia sesuai kebutuhanmu,
memungkinkan siapa saja melakukan hal-hal
seperti membangun quantum circuit pertamamu,
menjalankan algoritma kuantum lintas domain,
dan mempelajari fenomena kuantum fundamental.
Mungkin sekarang adalah waktu yang tepat untuk mulai terlibat
dan menemukan semua alat yang kamu butuhkan,
termasuk mesin kuantum sungguhan
dan SDK melalui Qiskit,
serta komunitas yang dengan senang hati menyambut
dan menjawab pertanyaan apa pun yang mungkin kamu punya di sepanjang perjalanan.
Kamu bisa mulai hari ini
di Qiskit.